et pour en parler nous retrouvons direct
de londres notre reporter basse m shelly
bonsoir bassem j -1 donc avant la date
officielle du bric cité des jalons qui
se prépare un 31 janvier de festivités
qui divise les onglets quelle est
l'atmosphère à londres et le programme
de demain
effectivement c'est effectivement c'est
pas lui c'est vraiment un événement
historique que s'apprête à vivre londres
un événement qui divise les anglais
entre les pro-aubry exit les antilles
habré existe déjà depuis le début de
l'après midi sur le parvis de once
mister juste derrière moi les antilles
et breakbeat sont réunis et sont
toujours présents ici avec des drapeaux
européen et des drapeaux complètement le
lumineux ils sont bien décidés à rester
ici et se faire entendre pour rester
dans l'union européenne il parle
notamment de déchirures d'abandon et
même d'être orphelins ainsi la grande
bretagne kit union européenne et c'est
bien ce qui va se passer demain ils sont
là depuis tout à l'heure avec des
slogans hostiles à boris johnson johnson
qui devrait prendre la parole demain
pour cet événement historique que les
anglais vont vivre des festivités qui
devrait commencer à partir de 21h30 avec
un écran géant qui devrait être disposés
ici big ben ne sonnera pas car beaven
étant en travaux mais de nombreuses
équipements qui seront disposées ici
pour imiter les sons de cloche de big
band et prises de paroles des discours
des festivités beaucoup d'activités qui
seront organisées demain à partir de 21
heures 30 et ce jusqu'à 23 heures
certains députés très pro breakes sites
ont même décidé d'organiser une soirée
très tard dans la nuit sur le thème de
l'angleterre avec un repas typiquement
anglais du vin typiquement anglais elle
a même déclaré qu'il n'y aura pas de vin
aux français pour souligner ce
nationaliste ont signé cette fierté
britannique et cette sortie de l'union
européenne boris johnson tant qu'à lui
va prendre la parole pour un discours à
la nation depuis le 10 downing street
et puis il y aura ce bien sûr cette
prise de parole et un cadran lumineux
qui sera que refus qui sera projeté sur
la façade du 10 downing street pour
représenter bien sûr big ben qui pourra
pas raisonner à demain et pour
représenter surtout les
dix coups de minuit avant cet événement
historique la sortie du royaume-uni a
depuis le brésil mais ce n'est pas une
sortie que se rabat automatiquement fait
à partir de demain elle sera très longue
à l'euro près leurs preuves apprendra à
peu près onze mois donc on ne parle d'un
divorce qui est acté mais le cadre reste
encore à définir
et puis bien sûr nous reviendrons demain
dans le courant de la journée sur ces
festivités que les britanniques
s'apprêtent à vivre
merci bassem chenilles en direct de
londres